you turned 47 in december new year's eve
to be exact that's right right so how
was that was it like oh
2020 is about to be lit or you know what
here's more inside scoop
i got these highlights on that day these
highlights have lasted
eight months because of covid i didn't
know a highlight job could
work that way you get what you pay for
that is true you know kim kardashian
west has had a lot of hair color in her
day
and today is her 40th birthday and she's
celebrating but not how she planned
yeah kim's wild wild miss west themed
bash was cancelled due to pandemic
instead a source is telling e.t that she
is spending the day with friends and
family
just on a little island that's it keep
it safe ken
but e.t still wants to celebrate with
you anyway yes indeed we're flashing
back to when we first met
kim k my name is kim kardashian i'm the
dopest and the ropest
person in this class i'm dope in a row
yeah that's kim at her eighth grade
graduation
does everyone get a tape of this because
i hope you do so you can see me when i'm
famous and all day remember me okay
i'm just a beautiful little girl but the
very first time we met her kim was just
12 years old at home with her family you
never knew hollywood was going to be
this easy did you
alright we're ready the reality star
whose life's an open book now was a lot
different back then
i'm definitely not against plastic
surgery especially when i'm older and i
have kids
there's no pressure to do that to be
thin you know that's kind of ridiculous
that's part of the reason
and here's how kim k used to react when
cameras followed her
i was in a store the other day and there
was all this paparazzi at the front of
the window
and i like asked the sales person i'm
like this here's britney spears here oh
my god they're like
no like you over the decades we've
witnessed kim's evolving look from paris
hilton's bestie to a fashion icon in her
own right
worth a reported 780 million dollars
well you're best known for your booty
to put it mildly i don't think i i could
really get rid of it or lose it i'll
miss you all
and i know you'll all miss me because
you all love me